[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta slomker guten Abend
Demokraten zeichnen sich ja dadurchaus
dass sie Wahlniederlagen hinnehmen und
dementsprechend auch aus
regierungssitzen klaglos wieder
ausziehen einschließlich ordnungsgemäßer
Übergabe an die Nachfolger autokratisch
gesonnene Politiker hingegen haben genau
damit ein gewaltiges Problem wie sich
etwa in den USA bei der Abwahl Trumps
beobachten ließ nun zeigt sich in Polen
die peacepartei ebenfalls äußerst
unwillig einzusehen dass sie die Macht
abgeben muss ihre verzögerungstaktiken
endeten dann aber heute mit einem
ziemlich unwürdigen Spektakel im
Parlament und vor den Augen der Nation
die das teilweise sogar auf kinolin
wenden verfolgte Linda kierstern
berichtet aus
Warschau Polens popcornm ein passendes
Bild um tuskweg zurück an die Macht zu
beschreiben seit der Wahl verfolgen
hunderttausende polenen und Polen jeden
noch so lange Sitzungen Parlament online
oder wie heute sogar im Kino der
Machtwechsel so spannend wie ein Film
aber real viele wollen das nicht
verpassen ich bin gekommen um zu feiern
um das Ende der herrschft
ichin zuende
geht die Menschen wollen sehen wie eine
er endet und eine neue beginnt die neue
er beginnt kurz vor 19 Uhr als Donald
Tusk die Abstimmung zum
Ministerpräsidenten gewinnt mit 248
stimmen die peace hatte diesen Moment
mit allen möglichen Mitteln versucht zu
verzögern bis dies ausgereiz waren
Wochen nach der Wahl beginnt in Polen
der
Machtwechsel ich bin stolz auf euch auf
jene die Angst hatten aber bis zum
Schluss nicht aufgegeben haben in der
Tat ist dieser Sieg den schwächsten zu
verdanken denjenigen die acht Jahre am
meisten verfolgt
wurden peace Parteichef Kinski reagiert
als wäre er noch im Wahlkampf bezeichnet
Tusk als deutschen Agenten seine Politik
als Gefahr für die Demokratie auf die
Frage ob er Tusk gratulieren werde
antwortet Kinski einem
Journalisten machen sie Witze pol es
zieht sich durch den ganzen Tag bereits
am Vormittag als noch Ministerpräsident
morwiki seine Version der Zukunft Polens
vorträgt eine Zukunft die selbst nicht
in der Hand haben wird moravzki verliert
am Nachmittag die Vertrauensfrage doch 8
Jahre peace haben Spuren hinterlassen
will Tusk seine Versprechen warrmchen
wird er mehr als nur Geduld brauchen das
ist ein sehr schweres Erbe und er wird
sich auch sehr schwer
tun die notwendigen
Reformen oder alle notwendigigen der
Reform mit sauberen Mitteln durch
durchzuführen also das große Dilemma vor
dem steht wie stellt man die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit wiederher ohne die
rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien zu
verletzen und das wird glaube ich die
tuskreierung in den kommenden Monaten
beschäftigen die Herausforderungen für
die neue Regierung sind groß doch der
Sieg der Opposition über die peace hat
für Experten noch eine ganz andere
Bedeutung das das erste Mal dass eine
illiberales
Regime in Europa in den letzten Jahren
abgewählt ist das ist in Ungarn nicht
gelungen das ist in Serbien nicht
gelungen das ist in der Türkei nicht
gelungen das ist aber in Polen gelungen
und das gibt Hoffnung dass dass eben
diese populistische liberale Welle rüäe
gemacht wird zurück zum Popcorn Moment
der neue Präsident des same hatte den
Menschen Action und Spannung versprochen
ebenwi im Kino aus Sicht dieser
Zuschauer gab es heute sogar ein Happy
[Musik]
End die meisten anderen Europäer hoffen
dass mit Tusk manches leichter wird
allerdings gibt es da ja auch noch den
neugewählten
antiuropapopulisten fizzo der Slowakei
und den ewigen Victor Orban Ungarns
Regierungschef tritt auch aktuell wieder
als Verhinderer auf am Donnerstag und
Freitag ist EU-Gipfel in Brüssel ein
zentrales Thema wird der Umgang mit der
Ukraine sein bleiben die Europäer
solidarisch oder wird Vladimir Putin
Recht behalten der auf nachlassende
Unterstützung des Westens setzt
mit Victor Orban hat Moskau jedenfalls
eine Stimme an Europas
verhandlungstischen bisher lehnt Ungarn
alles ab was der Ukraine helfen könnte
Geld oder Beitrittsverhandlungen gun
Krüger berichtet es ist ein ziemlich
dickes Album an dem der
Europaabgeordnete Daniel Freund da
bastelt die schönsten Handshakes
zwischen Wladimir Putin victtor Orban
und ihren Ministern und die Ungarn
scheinen sehr stolz daruf zu sein also
sie lassen sich Orden anpinnen und
veröffentlichen all diese Bilder wir
sehen im Grunde ihn als direkten
Handlanger von von Putin gestern ist
Viktor Orban in Argentinien
Amtseinführung beim Populisten Javier m
doch Orban trifft wohl eher zufällig auf
volodomir selenski man habe so sagt der
Ukrainer später sehr offen gesprochen
über Europa dort in Brüssel kommt am
Morgen Orbans Außenminister
an zu Musik wie im
Krim es ist klar sagt Peter shiato sie
wollen uns dazu bringen eine
Entscheidung mitzutragen die für uns
nicht annehmbar
ist die Außenminister bereiten den
eugipfel vor also eben die Entscheidung
die Ungarn nicht mragen will es geht um
den Status des EU
Beitrittskandidaten für die
Ukraine ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen ich will nicht mal drüber
reden über die zerstörerischen Folgen
die es hätte wenn der EU-Gipfel diese
Entscheidung nicht treffen
würde für die ukrainische Regierung
scheint der beitrittsstatus mittlerweile
so wichtig wie Militärhilfen für die
denen selenski Orden Verleih wäre eine
Ablehnung mindestens
demotivierend das wissen sie in Brüssel
der Außenminister von Ungarn genau wie
der Außenbeauftragte der EU ihren Ärger
kann man sehen und
hören ich kann aus Ungarns Haltung nur
so viel rauslesen sie sind gegen Europa
und gegen alles wofür Europa
steht Europa steht für den Rechtsstaat
und sperrt weil Ungarn da Defizite hat
noch immer Gelder manche sorgen
sich es sollte kein Geschacher werden
Daniel Freund der Europaabgeordnete
befürchtet genau das und schickt sein
Album an die EU Spitze als Mahnung denn
im Sommer hat Ungarn Tonus gemäß die
Ratspräsidentschaft der der durch die
Welt reist und sich mit einem
schukenstat nach dem anderen trifft
leitet dann also
den Club unserer Demokratien in der in
der Europäischen Union in der Geschichte
der EU wäre das ein ganz neues
Album für die Ukraine muss es jedenfalls
ziemlich furchtbar sein festzustellen
dass sowohl die Europäer als ja auch die
Amerikaner nicht in die Pötte kommen mit
ihren jeweiligen
Haushaltsverhandlungen und damit große
überlebenswichtige Hilfen in Frage
stehen und da geht es nicht nur um
Waffenlieferungen sondern auch um zivile
richtung Tim Kröger berichtet aus
HAK selbst in den heftigsten Monaten des
Krieges hat dieses Krankenhaus in hakiv
nicht aufgehört zu arbeiten dem
permanenten Beschuss und der drohenden
russischen Eroberung zum Trotz viele
Menschen verließen die Stadt aber
Krankenschwestern und Ärzte wie ihur
kuszov sind
geblieben ich lebe seit zwei Jahren ohne
Familie ein Jahr habe ich im Krankenhaus
zusammen mit meinen Ärzten gelebt weil
wir zu wenig
obwoh die Belegschaft stark ausgedt
wareb die Arbeit im Krankenhaus für
keine einzige Stunde
stehen seine Frau und seine beiden
Kinder hat er in Sicherheit gebracht
denn hakiv wird bis heute regelmäßig
beschossen wie auch an diesem Morgen die
russische Grenze ist nur wenige
Kilometer entfernt das Krankenhaus ist
wichtig auch über die Stadt hakiv
hinaus wir behandeln alle Menschen aus
hakiv aus der Region aus den besetzten
Gebieten und nahe der Front
hier verfolgen sie die Verhandlungen in
Brüssel ganz genau denn die Ukraine muss
fast alles Geld in die Verteidigung
stecken deswegen ist das Land auf
internationale Milliardenhilfen und
Kredite angewiesen um die Verwaltung
Schulen und Krankenhäuser am Laufen zu
halten wenn die 50 Milliarden der EU
nicht kommen könnte das Folgen
haben ich gehe davon aus dass wir dann
nicht nur geplante Operationen für
unsere Bürger absagen
müssen
sondern auch die dringendsten
medizinischen Eingriffe nicht mehr
durchführen
können hier im Krankenhaus wird Geld
auch dringend gebraucht um im Falle von
Angriffen auf elektrizitäts und
Heizkraftwerke den Betrieb am Laufen zu
halten etwa mit Generatoren vor allem
aber die Gehälter sind wichtig damit
nicht noch mehr Personal
wegeht
Mitarbeiter normal zu bezahlen dann
verlieren wir Sie und die Belegschaft
ist das
wichtigste denn auch Lehrer und Ärzte
sorgen dafür dass die Ukraine diesen
Krieg
übersteht der Krieg und die notwendige
Unterstützung für die Ukraine das könnte
womöglich noch der gemeinsame Nenner
sein der die Berliner Ampelkoalition aus
ihrem haushaltsdilemma rettet indest
wird seit dem Wochenende darüber
spekuliert dass sich Finanzminister
Christian Lindner mit dieser Begründung
darauf einlassen könnte für 2024 noch
mal eine Notlage auszurufen zumindest
für die ukrainehilfe die auch der
fdpchef als Investition in Deutschlands
Sicherheit sieht da gebe er
Bundeskanzler Scholz recht hatte er über
Social Media mitgeteilt ob das nun
wirklich ein Zeichen ist dass man sich
da näher kommt sei hingestellt
vielleicht weiß man morgen mehr zur
Stunde sprechen sie wieder miteinander
aus Berlin Frank
buchwal auf nichts lauert die
Hauptstadtpresse in diesen Tagen so sehr
wie auf Hinweise wo all das Geld
herkommen soll dass der Regierung fehlt
Olaf Scholz hatte heute Mark rütte zu
Gast den Liberalen Ministerpräsidenten
der Niederlande dabei ganz en Passon ein
kanzlerwort zum
Haushaltsstreit und was in Deutschland
die Gespräche betrifft ist die Aufgabe
groß aber wir sind so weit vorangekommen
dass man sehr zuversichtlich sein kann
dass wir es auch schaffen werden das
Ergebnis ihn bald mitzuteilen mit
anderen Worten wir lassen uns nicht in
die Karten schauen das gilt auch heute
abend stundenlang beraten der Kanzler
Finanzminister Lindner und Vize habbeck
und wieder dürfte nicht viel nach außen
dringen der Wirtschaftsminister kommt
aus dem sarland auch er ziemlich
zugeknöpft also nicht besonders einfach
das hin zu bekommen aber wir kommen ganz
gut voran und ja also wir kommen gut
voran heißt dass ich hier nach auch
wieder weiter arbeiten muss Christian
Lindner heute bei einer FDP
Veranstaltung zur aktienrente zum
Haushalt kein Wort die Liberalen so viel
ist klar wollen die Schuldenbremse
einhalten zu groß die Gefahr abermals in
chaosruhe zu scheitern das kann diese
Bundesregierung aus meiner Sicht nicht
gebrauchen das wäre auch
suboptimal für das Ansehen dieser
Bundesregierung von daher ist es aus
meiner sich gut dass man jetzt sehr
gründlich arbeitet nicht ohne Grund die
Opposition rüstet sich bereits für
weitere Klagen falls die Koalition per
notstandsbeschluss die Schuldenbremse
außer Kraft setzt ich würde eine Klage
zumindest mal nicht ausschließen ich
finde eine Notlage ist auf den ersten
Blick nicht ersichtlich in Wahrheit will
die Regierung wollen Teile der Regierung
sich ja nur drücken um die Frage wo sie
denn Prioritäten setzen wo sie denn
einsparen um eben an anderen Stellen
Dingen möglich zu machen genau darüber
grübeln sie stundenlang nachts im
Kanzleramt zündende die Ideen
verzweifelt
gesucht der Ampelkoalition dabei
zuzusehen wie sie sich durch die Mühen
der Regierungsebene pflügt könnte beim
eine der anderen auf den
Oppositionsbänken tief im Innern auch
mit einem leisen Gefühl der
Erleichterung einhergehen gut dass man
dieses haushaltsfiasko nicht selbst
lösen muss andererseits wusste ja schon
ein prominenter aldemokrat Opposition
ist Mist vor allem aber ist Opposition
ja unbedingt erforderlich für eine
funktionierende parlamentarische
Demokratie und zwar nicht nur eine
destruktive Opposition sondern eine die
als
regierungsalternative jederzeit parat
steht wie sich die CDU dafür aufstellen
und profilieren will das präsentierte
sie heute mit ihrem Entwurf für ein
neues Grundsatzprogramm mit welchen
Akzenten berichtet mattis fel
lange war es Verschlusssache fast geheim
das neue Grundsatzprogramm der CDU heute
legt Generalsekretär Carsten linemann an
71 seitenpier vor die CDU sei wieder da
so sein ziemlich dick aufgetragenes Lob
und das nicht nur programmatisch die CDU
Deutschlands ist wieder regierungsfähig
wir sind wieder
regierungsfähig sollte es zu einer
vorgezzogenen Bundestagswahlen kommen
wären wir bereit z jah haben die
Christdemokraten unter ihrem neuen
Vorsitzenden märz an den Programm
geschrieben ein Jahr zur Kernkraft ein
neues Asylrecht Schwerpunkt innere
Sicherheit einen mühsamen Prozess hatte
sich die CDU auferlegt viele Debatten
auch mit politischen Gegnern manches
scheint sich jetzt wiederzufinden als
eine Partei die auch konservativ ist
nicht nur müssen sie
ja die Brücke schlagen zwischen
konservativen Grundbedürfnissen wie
Sicherheit und einer Zeit stürmischen
Wandels jetzt trennt sich die Union fast
geräuschlos von der ERA Merkel nicht
weil sie Merkel negiert sondern weil der
stürmische Wandel sie irgendwie
hinweggefegt hat die Zeile die dies am
meisten verkörpert lautet Muslime die
unsere Werte teilen gehören zu
Deutschland alle anderen wohl nicht das
steht dann doch im Kontrast zu den
Worten eines Ex-Bundespräsidenten und
der ehemaligen Kanzlerin ja von meiner
Seite möchte ich sagen dass unser
früherer Bundespräsident Christian Wulf
gesagt hat der Islam gehört zu
Deutschland und das ist so diese Meinung
bin ich auch jetzt soll die Partei
diskutieren und im Mai nächsten Jahres
darüber abstimmen wohl auch über die
Distanz zu Merkel es ist in der Tat so
dass nach 16 Regierungsjahren es auch
eine inhaltliche Abnutzung gegeben hat
und deshalb ist es ganz wichtig dass wir
die letzten Z Jahre genutzt haben auch
für intensive programmatische Debatten
herausgekommen sind Reizworte über die
man vor 20 Jahren noch heftig gestritten
hatte und die heute CDU Konsens sind
leidkultur Leitbild Ehe und Familie
leistung muss sich
lohnen wir verstehen die Leitkultur und
definieren Sie in unserem unserem
Grundsatzprogramm auch so als ein
Fördermittel für den gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt die CDU wird wieder
konservativer und glaubt sich damit im
Einklang mit den Bürgern die größte
Neuausrichtung vollzieht sie bei der
Asylpolitik wir wollen einen
grundlegenden Wandel des Asylrechts
steht im Programmentwurf die CDU will
Asylverfahren künftig außerhalb der EU
man folge den Experten die sagen dass
man am Ende des Tages ein Konzept
braucht dass nur noch diejenigen kommen
können die bereits einen positiven
Asylbescheid Entscheid haben ob solche
Vorstellungen allerdings den
Realitätscheck eine Prüfung in Karlsruhe
oder die Vertragstreue der
Aufnahmeländer bestehen hat die CDU
heute nicht
beantwortet
bei der Weltklimakonferenz in Dubai gab
es heute einen regelrechten eklar damit
beginnen bei dir die Nachrichten Heinz
es gab einen neuen Entwurf für den
abschlusstext und Außenministerin
berbock sagte dazu für Deutschland und
die EU nicht akzeptabel streitpunkt ist
dass der neue Text kein gemeinsames
Bekenntnis zum weltweiten Ausstieg aus
allen fossilen Energien mehr enthält
Außenministerin berbur sagte der Text
sei nicht ausreichend und enttäuschend
er sende das irreführende Signal aus
dass Gas Öl und selbst Kohle in unserer
Zukunft weiterhin eine Rolle spielen
können damit ist das Ende der Konferenz
offen die laut Plan nur noch bis morgen
angesetzt
ist die israelische Armee setzt im
Einsatz gegen hamaskämpfer ihre Angriffe
auf Ziele im Süden des Gazastreifens
fort am stärksten betroffen ist die
Stadt han Junis nach israelischen
Angaben waren zuvor Raketen aus Gaza auf
israelisches Gebiet abgefeuert worden
die Hamas droht erneut damit alle
Geiseln zu töten sollte Israel nicht
alle palästinensischen Inhaftierten
freilassen in der FDP wird es eine
Mitgliederbefragung über den Verbleib in
der Ampelkoalition geben wie der
Parteivorstand mitteilte liege dafür ein
wirksamer Antrag von
598 FDP Mitgliedern vor die Online
Befragung solle schnellst möglich
beginnen einen genauen Termin nannte man
noch nicht das Ergebnis gilt als
Stimmungsbild bindend ist es
nicht die Vereinten Nationen haben nach
10 Jahren ihre Friedensmission minusma
in Mali beendet auch die Bundeswehr war
daran beteiligt bei einer
Abschlusszeremonie in der Hauptstadt
Bamako wurde die Flagge der Vereinten
Nationen als symbolische Gäste eingeholt
das letzte Personal soll bis Ende des
Jahres Mali verlassen die seit einem
Putsch im Jahr 2020 regier militärunter
hatte den Abzug der Blauhelme gefordert
und stattdessen die Zusammenarbeit mit
Russland
verstärkt bei der deutschen fußballiga
dürfen künftig externe Investoren
einsteigen eine Mehrheit der Deutschen
Proficlubs hat sich dafür ausgesprochen
unter anderem mit dem Argument dass die
Bundesliga ansonsten international den
Anschluss verliert im Mai hat es darüber
ja schon mal eine Abstimmung gegeben da
war der Antrag noch scheitert nun also
die Wiedervorlage eine Nummer kleiner
mögliche Anteile und Summen wurden
stärker begrenzt aus Sicht vieler Fans
ist die Richtung aber dennoch klar und
klar falsch sie befürchten dass der
deutsche Fußball sich ähnlich entwickeln
wird wie die englische Premier League
die von den Milliarden geprägt wird die
ausländische Investoren hineinpumpen
darunter Baulöwen Scheichs und
Oligarchen Mark Windgassen berichtet
die Richtung ist klar nach der
Entscheidung externe Investoren bei der
deutschen fußballiga zuzulassen es geht
um Geld um rund eine Milliarde Euro die
sich die DFL erhofft um damit das
Produkt Bundesliga zu stärken wir wollen
uns natürlich mit den anderen liegen
messen wollen unseren zweiten Platz
hinter der Premier League sichern und
dazu war die Entscheidung notwendig doch
die Entscheidung der 36 erst und
Zweitliga Clubs viel knapp aus zwei
Drittel stimten für ja exakt 24 also es
hätte keine Stimme weniger sein dürfen
einige Vereine haben sich dann im
Vergleich zum Erstantrag im Mai doch
noch umstimmen lassen wohl auch durch
das abgeschwächte Angebot vorbealte gibt
es auch wenn es gro der Topvereine dies
anders
sieht wir haben Abstimmung die eine
klare Mehrheit gebracht hat sie
entsprach dem was wir auch uns gewünscht
haben nämlich dass die
Mitgliederversammlung dafür gestimmt hat
in eine Entwicklung der Liga in eine
Gestaltungsmöglichkeit in ein eine
Weiterentwicklung was die digitale
inachstruktur betrifft und damit sind
wir ganz zufrieden die größte Opposition
jedoch kommt aus dem fennlager der
Investoren auch einem maximalen
Renditedruck unterliegen heißt wer Geld
gibt möchte Gewinn erzielen man
befürchtet also eine zu große
Einflussnahme auf die Vereine was die
clubbosse aber
verneinen nur als Beispiel sei da
genannte die Frage um einen Spielplan
oder die Ansetzung von Spielen oder die
Idee die womöglich jand haben könnte der
nicht aus Deutschland kommt dass man
auch Ligaspiele im Ausland machen kann
und ähnliches all dieses ist völlig klar
gesetzt in den Voraussetzungen überhaupt
jetzt an diesem Investorenprozess
teilzunehmen dass das alles ein
absolutes NoGo ist der Deal ist da das
Interesse auch gleich vier Investoren
sind bereit bei der DFL
einzusteigen also ob am Ende eine
Partnerschaft kommt ist ja auch noch
nicht gesagt es gibt bestimmte Parameter
bestimmte
rote Linien und die müssen ja auch noch
mit möglichen Partnern verhandelt werden
von daher ist heute nur ein kleiner
Schritt gemacht worden und die Arbeit
fängt für die Geschäftsführung und
Präsidium jetzt erst richtig an durch
den Ausbau der digitalen Infrastruktur
erhofft sich die DFL mehr Einnahme aus
der Vermarktung der Medienrechte was
parallel auch ein gewisses Risiko birgt
sollte das Vorhaben scheitern wird die
deutsche fußballiga versuchen den
Verlust auszugleichen erster
Ansprechpartner wären dann wohl die
Fußballclubs die die Zeche zahlen
müssten und jetzt geht's bei dir noch
mal weiter Heinz mit Wirtschaft auf dem
Weg zur Nutzung anderer Energiequellen
in Deutschland gab es heute zwei
wichtige Meldungen bei denen es um
Milliardensummen geht Frank betmann
lassen Sie uns mit der Stahlindustrie
beginnen da gab es heute eine Zusage von
Wirtschaftsminister habbeck und zwar für
das Saarland eine Zusage auf die man
dort schon lange gewartet hat eine
milliardenschwere Unterstützung des
Staates beim Umbau auf eine grüne
Produktion in mitten des
haushaltsstreitsreis der Harbeck heute
nach v in um selbst die Entscheidung zu
präsentieren 2,6 Milliarden Euro
Fördergeld soll die saarländische
Stahlindustrie dafür erhalten davon
übernimmt der Bund etwa zwei Drittel das
Saarland rund ein Drittel habbeck sprach
heute von der größten Einzelförderung
die die Bundesrepublik jemals in der
Geschichte zugesichert habe und
versicherte man sei auch mit der EU
rechtweit die Beihilfe rechtliche
Genehmigung stehe kurz bevor mit dem
Thema Beil Genehmigung sind wir dann
auch gleich bei RWE da geht's um den
Kohleausstieg genau durch den entgehen
RWE laut EU hohe Gewinne deshalb darf
der Bund dem Energiekonzern staatliche
Hilfen im Wert von 2,6 Milliarden Euro
zahlen mit dieser Beihilfe werde RWE für
die vorzeitige Stilllegung seiner
Braunkohlekraftwerke im Rheinischen
Revier entschädigt der Energieriese ist
gerade dabei sein Geschäft mit
Milliardensummen umzubauen früher Kohle
und Kernkraft heute zunehm mehr Strom
aus erneuerbaren Energien Frank betmann
vielen
Dank die deutschen Handballerinnen haben
am Abend ihr letztes Gruppenspiel der
Weltmeisterschaft gegen Dänemark mit 28
Z3 verloren und damit den Gruppensieg
knapp verpasst für das Viertelfinale
hatte sich die DHB Auswahl bereits zuvor
qualifiziert die deutschen
Fußballerinnen Treffen im Halbfinale der
nations League auf Frankreich das ergab
die Auslosung der UEFA bei dem Turnier
geht es auch um die Teilnahme an den
Olympischen Spielen in Paris die das
deutsche Team mit einem Sieg gegen die
Französinnen bereits sicher hätte das
zweite Halbfinale bestreiten Spanien und
die
Niederlande es gibt eine aktuelle
Unwetterwarnung des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes gewarnt wird vor starkem
Tauwetter in Teilen Bayerns Tauwetter
und anhaltender Niederschlag haben in
Süd und Westdeutschland zu steigenden
Wasserständen und vereinzelt zu
Hochwasser geführt offen sind vor allem
Baden-Württemberg und Bayern besonders
schnell ist der Pegelstand der großen
Filz angestiegen bei filsbburg im
Landkreis Landshut gilt derzeit die
Warnstufe 3 von vier dort wurden bereits
Straßen überflutet die Hochwassergefahr
in Bayern soll auch die nächsten Tage
andauern und dann hat uns hier im ZDF
heute noch eine traurige Nachricht
erreicht unser früherer Intendant Dieter
Stolte ist gestorben 20 Jahre lang war
er Intendant von
1982 bis 2002 eine ganze eha eine ganze
Generation hat er geleitet und geprägt
und dieses Schiff durch unruhige Zeiten
und hohe Wellen gesteuert er selbst
sagte mal der Intendant ist Manager
Impressario und Psychotherapeut in einem
insgesamt hat er gut 40 Jahre für diesen
Sender gearbeitet dazu FST der Titel
seiner Memoiren mein Leben mit dem ZDF
entsprechend viele Erinnerungen teilt
unser Haus mit ihm und seiner Familie
Dieter Stolte wurde 89 Jahre alt Angela
ephart und Peter Wagner zeichnen sein
Lebensbild sich auf seinen lorben
auszuruhen das war nichts für ihn Arbeit
war sein Leben ganz oben aus dem 14
Stock lenkte Dieter Stolte die Geschicke
des Senders 20 Jahre lang als ZDF in war
immer jemand der sehr gerne gearbeitet
hat und der gestaltet hat und der
Arbeiten nie als eine als eine froh
empfunden hat Bescheidenheit
beharlichkeit Anstand und ein
bemerkenswertes strategisches Geschick
das haben sie ihm von allen Seiten immer
wieder
attestiert als Dieter Stolte ging blieb
auch er nicht ungerührt 2002 sein
Abschied vom ZDF
schon bei den Anfängen des ZDF in der
Schlammwüste von esppor 1963 war Dieter
Stolte dabei als Referent des
gründungsintendanten später wird Stolte
planungschef dass die
hauptnachrichtensendung auf 19 Uhr
rückte und damit ein neues bis heute
wirksames Programmschema entstand sein
Verdienst unter seiner Egide wird
Fernsehgeschichte
geschrieben
Dieter Stolte war einer der prägenden
Architekten des ztf in seinen Amtszeiten
sind so wichtige programmmarken
entstanden wie z.B Terra X oder auch der
Fernsehfilm der Woche und die Bildungs
und kulturkanäle dreisat und Arte sind
von ihm mitbegründet worden genauso wie
der Ereignis und dokumentationskanal
phöniix oder auch der gemeinsame
Kinderkanal von AD und ZDF die der
Stolte war ein Verfechter des
öffentlichrechtlichen Systems und auch
einer seiner wichtigsten Vordenker wir
im TDF haben ihm viel zu
verdanken Stolte der erfolgreiche
Medienmanager erhält 1997 in New York
den international y
Award eine Anerkennung die ihm besonders
wichtig war Widerstände fordern ihn
heraus zielstrebig verfolgte dier Stolte
seinen Weg konsequentes Handeln
und konsequentes Verfolgen von einmal
für richtig Erkannte Ziele das ist der
Weg zum Erfolg im Krieg hat Stolte die
Bombennächte in Berlin überlebt als
19-Jährige verließ er die DDR nach der
Wiedervereinigung das ZDF neu zu
positionieren das war für ihn vielleicht
der Höhepunkt seiner
Karriere das war eine großartige
Erfahrung das war eine Aufgabe die auch
einem
Intendanten in der Zukunft so schnell
nicht wieder fahren kann sein Amt seine
Persönlichkeit nutzteet St intensiv für
den Denkmalschutz in den neuen Ländern
bemerkenswert die zdfaktion zum
Wiederaufbau der dresner
Frauenkirche 2012 präsentiert Dieter
Stolte im Hauptstadtstudio sein Buch mit
persönlichen Erinnerungen an das ZDF ein
stolzer Blick zurück auf die Zeit als
Intendant es ist kein parteipolitisches
aber ist ein politisches man muss ein
politischer Mensch sein wenn man es
wirklich ausfüllen und gestalten will
Dieter Stolte war ein Fernsehmann durch
und durch auch wenn er nach 40 Jahren
noch einmal das Medium wechselte und als
Herausgeber der Welt zum Springerverlag
ging in Erinnerung bleibt er als der
Intendant des
ZDF und jetzt gleich im Anschluss sendet
das ZDF noch ein ausführlicheres
Lebensbild von Dieter Stolte und um 0
Uhr gibt's dann unser heute journal
Update mit nasan göckt mir und ein heute
journal dann morgen wieder auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
Widersehen schönen guten Abend Tauwetter
ist angesagt uns erreicht relativ milde
Luft von der Biskaya her dazu auch Regen
und dieser Regen setzt sich fort und
fällt in die weiße Pracht die wir
zuletzt hatten es viel ja viel Schnee an
den Alpen und im Alpenraum und der taut
jetzt teilweise weg und dieses Wasser
fließt in die Flüsse und in die Bäche
und so gibt's Überflutung und hohe
Pegelstände schauen wir uns die Nacht an
da gibt's im Süden Regen auch in der
Mitte regnet es nach Norden einzelne
Auflockerungen bei tiefsten Temperaturen
von 2° im Südosten und 9° am
oberrein ja und morgen kommt eine
Warmfront und die bringt den Regen mit
und dementsprechend gibt's dieses
anhaltende trauwetter im Westen bilden
sich einzelne Gewitter dieser
regenkomplex der wandert dann allmählich
nach Nordosten Temperaturen dazu
Maximalwerte mit 4° ganz im Norden 10°
ganz im Westen und die höchsten Werte
hier im am oberrein Richtung oberrein
mit 14°. die nächsten Tage weiterer
Regen am Mittwoch und das bei 2 bis 11°
Donnerstag wird schon kühler und der
geht allmädchen Schnee über das
Tauwetter lässt dann nach und im Norden
gibt's ein bisschen Sonnenschein Freitag
sogar noch ein bisschen mehr Sonne bei
hösten Werten von 0 bis 7° damit einen
schönen
Abend